welcome to this video I'm playing G roam
here from the US I've played him two
times two wins and what is it 33 makes
the charm or something like that there's
something like that check let's see if
my tried and trusted zimage can strike
yeah I like this structure not it's
normally quite comfortable for white
with the idea to play in the center f3
and deform being the plan yeah this is a
tactical way to defend against the 44
takes takes 95 and have blundered deform
so this is something that I need to be
aware of so maybe the night here
okay um again efore this 95 at the end
slight slight problem okay so should I
play Bishop to be too not sure what just
to d2 I don't know he might play night
f8 later
hmm now maybe here at droopy one that
shouldn't be too bad the moment he plays
9 f8 I can play your form and if he's
not doing that I don't really see a move
my men okay can play all kinds of stuff
but let's say Quincy seven again I have
any form maybe then it can take play
Quincy form for counter play maybe
maybe jump here takes takes I have 96 at
the end that's really a good square I
maybe maybe he can take and play Quincy
too but okay it's a it hasn't really
happened the check and then if or maybe
I am a bit off side with this night
efore yeah it's a bit of an offside
offside place
ok that's just let's just return the
dark squares have been considerably
weakened now takes hmm I can take with
the upon open up my bishop it's not not
bad really technically I can go here ok
what I want is to use my my dark squared
Bishop I am weak on the light squares
though it's um it's not like a one-way
street or anything some not clear to me
really maybe he can switch off switch
the rooks here to smoke the rooks lucky
one rookie aid mm that's not it's not
really great for me
check and Bishop age 6 next that's the
reason why I'm allowed this
transformation and get the bishop him
Queenie oneness protecting c3 and I have
Queenie 7 as an as an aggressive IDM
that's quite serious at least I hope
yeah he wants to wants to play with
Queenie aid and I understand there's
some way to to make it more difficult
for him to do that night f5 maybe night
f5 takes Queen g3 check this is quite
good yeah maybe here intending 97 maybe
he can still play no Queenie 8i can
exchange and win the d5 pawn that's very
important whoo okay and this this gets
this gets problematic for black now I
have various active ideas 97 not easy
for him to play yeah maybe this one okay
if I play Queenie seven isn't this just
a good end game this is a good end
camera takes Knight takes King age 8 and
g4 is a very good end game he can he has
a very very hard time to move his pieces
98 an IgA does the defense ah ah that's
that's bad okay
a g5 rg5 have aged five that's no
problem
yeah I need to try to play against his
his night I have this point on dark
squares which is not not ideal so take
your king of fall it's okay
time warning
see foyer I get sequel in check
can I take with the poem hmm he has the
chick but enjoy our King defy if I
didn't see that one
mmm very bad I overlooked a lot of Lucas
mix very very bad play check oh man
that's a really bad run white resides
and I even get outplayed in the Zen
gamey unbelievable it's totally equal
yeah lc4 was mistyped I cannot I
shouldn't do that something like this
don't really shouldn't be okay the
counter play idea i mean should save me
I shouldn't just play it right away
chaffee goes like this for example then
I get in c4 and I get the counter play
that I need with a draw but the bad
thing really was to to get into this end
game at all I mean here here g4 while g4
is the normal positional move of course
it takes away aged five gain space but
he's got 98 yeah this is the problem he
threatened this silly move which which
helps him if i go here he can resign
basically I just attack here and he
cannot move move anything here ah a
place without the king yeah look just
have a look at this like like here sure
also entering here a 6a for something
like this yeah this is this is just
losing he has a very passive position
and will lose the beep on oh man if it
rains it pours him no it was really nice
I was really satisfied with all this
this was very nice
and Queenie seven is really the way to
go and then I played g4 is the normal
move in a way yeah it would be
convenient to gain space and so on and
yeah but he's got 98 and this is just
saving him completely yeah now he's got
this this good night against my bishop
okay it's wrong but right here if I go
Knights eatum it's it's simply over oh
man okay thanks for watching